Well, first of all, we have an external CSS
file which we need to construct the CSSOM. So, if
I inline that, then that could save a lot
of time. Same goes for JavaScript. If I inline that,
then we can skip the request. And in fact,
if I inline both, then that's even better because my
critical path length will be one. As soon as
I have my HTML file, I have everything I need.
>> Yep, that's right. Those are definitely good strategies. Just be careful
when you apply them. Remember that inlining
a lot of JavaScript and CSS, especially when
those resources can be used between multiple
pages, can lead to a lot of overhead.
>> Right. Right. Good point. Alright, speaking of which, I guess, I
don't know if this applies to this exact case, but if I knew
what was inside the CSS and JavaScript files, then I could also
consider adding a media type to the CSS or making the script async.
>> Yep, you got it. Just to confirm though, what would
you look for in the CSS and JavaScript files?
>> Well, for CSS, I'd want to make
sure the styles are actually required to render the
page. If they're not being used, I could
add an appropriate media tag to attribute and unblock
rendering. Also, it's pretty much the same idea
for JavaScript. If the script is not manipulating or
accessing the DOM or CSSOM, then I could
add an async attribute, which would unblock DOM construction.
>> Yep. That's awesome.